Babylon 5 is leaving HBO Max but what
does that mean for the reboot if
anything
welcome to Sidetrack your Sci-Fi TV and
movie channel
[Music]
on January 25th the original Babylon 5
will be leaving HBO Max now I was a
little bit surprised by this news but to
be fair HBO Max like Netflix change up
their content almost constantly this
will have been a planned change probably
planned months ago at the end of the day
HBO Max only has so much space in its
service if it wants to put new content
onto the streamer service something has
to be removed but my instinct was well
what does this mean for the Babylon 5
reboot we've been so excited about now
for one thing I'm going to say I
actually think HBO Max put Babylon 5 on
in the first place around the time of
the announcement that JMS made about a
reboot to get the use it put it on there
and it would have got really decent
views because of the excitement
regarding the new show it was back in
people's Consciousness so they would
have gone and found Babylon 5 on there
and watched it and according to my
sources they did
it actually is done very very well
so why remove it now I've told you over
the last six months or so that Warner
Brothers yes do want to make Babylon 5
but they don't particularly want to put
it on the CW if it was up to them they
put it on hbr Max now the CW
unfortunately does have first pick on
this so Warner Brothers can't just say
we're going to put it where we like
there are contracts involved the CW has
first dibs but the CW don't seem to want
to produce this type of TV show they've
actually just signed a contract that
they're going to be showing live from
golf so
my opinion actually is that four Warner
Brothers Babylon 5 onto hbr Max is a
much better fit and I just to be honest
makes sense to me so why are they
removing the original series now well
you couldn't really have the original
series and the new series on there at
the same time that would be confusing
and a bit weird so I completely
understand that they would do that if it
was announced though tomorrow for
example the new Pablo 5 reboot was
happening you would again see a big
surge in views on HBO Max so why would
you remove it well the actual TV show is
still available for sale
um in different platforms particularly
on Amazon the remastered series one to
five so if the new Babylon 5 reboot was
announced the original isn't actually
available to watch anywhere so you would
have to go and buy it now am I being
cynical maybe a little bit but this
might actually be the plan
put it on get people interested take it
off
don't have anywhere that you can stream
it except sell it then announce a brand
new reboot and people will buy it
maximizing your profits
maybe that's the plan or maybe actually
the fact that it's being removed from
HBO Max is actually a sign that they're
not going to be moving forwards I did
tell you a couple of months ago actually
that it looked like it was done dead but
um now everything is sort of settled
down at Warner Brothers they were having
a look at it again now it was pushed to
the back burner this was supposed to be
announced a year ago JMS J Michael
suginski the creator of the TV show has
talked about how the you know the
decision was going to be made in coming
weeks months ago
now I don't know what this means moving
forwards it could really be either a
cash grab or it could mean that actually
HBO Max and Warner Brothers are not
interested in a reboot because again if
it was going to be announced they'd have
got an uptick in views but guys I'd love
to know what you think this is just a
short little video the update just
asking this question I'd love to know
what you think though get into the
comments and tell me if you are new to
the Channel please like subscribe hit
that Bell notification really helps us
out and if you want to support the
channel even more consider hitting that
join button all the links for our
Discord server merchandise etc etc are
all in the description as always please
stay safe and I'll see you next time
[Music]